je suis très honoré d'avoir été invité
moi qui ne suis absolument pas agro je
suis agro par ascendant voilà mais enfin
je sais pas si ça me rend compétent
à m'exprimer ici sur un sujet qui est
celui de l'agriculture et donc plus
généralement de la production de
nourriture je vais essayer de vous
restituer quelques petites choses que
j'ai compris en tant qu'observateur
extérieur et quelques éléments que
le sujet dont je m'occupe plus
classiquement c'est-à-dire le sujet
énergie et climat peut amener au débat
alors l'agriculture est un et quelque
chose qui sait profondément modifié mais
vraiment extrêmement profondément
modifié sur le dernier siècle
ça s'est modifié déjà quand on regarde
les volumes alors quand on regarde les
éléments quantitatifs dans un sens et
dans un autre il y a un premier élément
quantitatif moi qui me frappe et qui
aurait dû conduire à ce que les
productions n'augmentent pas du tout
c'est quand on regarde la quantité de
surface cultivable par personne sur
Terre en fait si on regarde cet
indicateur il arrête il a baissé il a
pas arrêté de baisser sur le dernier
siècle il y avait en moyenne mondial 1,6
hectares cultivables par personne en
1960 on est aujourd'hui un peu au-dessus
de 0,6
si on regarde la moyenne européenne on
est encore en dessous en Europe on est
en dessous de 0,4 hectares cultivables
par personne alors que pourtant dans le
même temps la quantité de nourriture
produite par personne n'a pas cessé
d'augmenter donc là l'indicateur
quantitatif va totalement dans l'autre
sens et en fait le miracle qui se trouve
aller à l'origine de cette de cette
asymétrie apparente s'appelle
précisément l'énergie ce qui s'est passé
en fait sur le dernier siècle c'est
qu'on a remplacé les gens
par des machines on avait des
agriculteurs qui binaient qui faisaient
des buts qui faisait avancer le cheval
qui etc aujourd'hui on a des machines
donc on a des tracteurs qui viennent à
la place des agriculteurs et qui
remplacent les chevaux on a du reste des
usines d'engrais qui remplacent la les
crottins des chevaux ou la bouse de
vache on a des camions et on a des
usines de l'industrie agroalimentaire
qui remplace la transformation à la
ferme et les marchés
du reste sans camion aujourd'hui les
villes meurent de faim un truc qu'il
faut bien avoir en tête c'est que la
dépendance aux hydrocarbures de la
chaîne alimentaire elle n'est pas que
dans le champ elle est très très
fortement à l'amont et à Laval du champ
un camion sur trois par exemple en
France aujourd'hui transporte quelque
chose qui se mange ou des animaux
vivants bon allez
mais donc je j'insiste sans sans camion
aujourd'hui toutes les métropoles
meurent de fin quand on parle le chiffre
qui a été évoqué juste avant la de
l'indépendance alimentaire de la France
s'il est dans une France avec camion
parce que dans une France sans camion
l'indépendance alimentaire c'est à
l'échelle du département qu'il faut la
considérer c'est plus à l'échelle du
pays
la raison pour laquelle les villes
étaient si petites à l'intérieur du pays
il y a des milliers d'années Lutèce
faisait 10000 habitants à peu près c'est
parce que à l'époque le surplus agricole
qu'on pouvait dégager dans un disque
dans le rayon était quelques jours de
transport à l'époque à pied ou en
charrette à deux étaient ridicule et
donc on pouvait pas faire vivre des
villes de millions ou de centaines de
milliers d'habitants la seule exception
de l'époque c'était Rome parce que Rome
était capable de piller le blé d'un
champ totalement desservi par voie
navigable qui s'appelait l'Egypte donc
vous aviez un champ de 2000 km de long
des servi par refuge qui s'appelait
l'Egypte et Rome était capable de servir
dans ce champ là et de tout piquer et
donc on pouvait faire vivre une ville
d'un million d'habitants mais c'était
une exception dans le dans le à l'époque
ancienne et il lui reste à l'époque les
villes portuaires étaient plus grosses
que les villes à l'intérieur des terres
à Marseille était plus grosses que que
Lutèce à cette époque là
donc il y a donc l'énergie à
radicalement modifier la façon dont
l'agriculture a été exercée alors ça
fait exploser les rendements ce qui
permet d'avoir plus de nourriture avec
des plus petites surfaces et c'est la
raison pour laquelle par exemple en
France on mangeait à peu près 20 kg de
viande par personne et par an en 1800 on
en mange aujourd'hui pas loin de 100 kg
même si la tendance à commencer à
légèrement s'éroder depuis quelques
décennies mais on est donc en gros on a
fait x 5 sur la viande en l'espace de
deux siècles alors que encore une fois
la surface cultivable par personne à
considérablement baissé et donc ce qui a
fait très fortement augmenter les
rendements je vais la prendre à personne
ici c'est les engrais azotés les autres
engrais minéraux et la mécanisation ce
qui a également permis de
considérablement augmenter la quantité
de nourriture servie c'est les moyens de
transport et de conservation la conserve
la surgélation le stockage les silos etc
tous ces trucs là
et les défis pour demain c'est que tout
ça va partiellement s’éroder puisque
l'énergie fossile que nous avons à notre
disposition elle est malheureusement pas
éternelle ou heureusement pas éternel et
que l'approvisionnement mondial en
énergie fossile et régionale en énergie
fossile climat ou pas climat ne peut que
baisser parce que pour tous ceux d'entre
vous qui ont fait les mêmes études de
maths que moi quand j'étais petit vous
savez que il y a un petit théorème en
maths qui dit que quand vous tapez dans
une ressource de départ qui est donnée
une fois pour toutes et bien la
production au cours du temps de issue de
cette ressource ne peut faire qu'un truc
comme ça
et donc ça veut dire que pour toutes les
ressources issues de la croûte terrestre
dont les combustibles fossiles qui
mettent des centaines de millions ou des
dizaines de millions d'années à se
reconstituer et bien on est forcé
d'avoir un maximum à l'extraction et un
déclin derrière or les combustibles
fossiles sont aujourd'hui indispensables
pour fabriquer la mécanisation agricole
ou du charbon et du gaz pour faire
fonctionner la mécanisation agricole il
faut du pétrole pour faire fonctionner
les transports aval il faut du pétrole
et pour fertiliser les champs il faut du
gaz il reste
un certain nombre d'entre vous sont
probablement au courant que depuis qu'on
a des démêlés avec Monsieur Poutine on a
eu un petit sujet sur
l'approvisionnement qui est pas majeur
mais sur l'approvisionnement en anglais
et tout ça s'est fait dans le cadre qui
a fait votre malheur à vous les agro qui
est l'effondrement économique du secteur
la nourriture représentait probablement
alors c'est un ordre de grandeur que
j'ai reconstitué avec mes petits bras
musclés donc il vaut ce qu'il vaut mais
il y a deux siècles la nourriture
représentait probablement entre 50% et
2/3 du budget des ménages c'est à dire
que acheter à manger
représentèrent entre la moitié et les
deux tiers de ce que les gens gagnent
la manière dont j'évalue ça c'est tout
simplement que la population active dans
l'agriculture et encore bouchez-vous les
oreilles mesdames à l'époque je pense
que on ne comptait pas les conjointes
d'agriculteurs comme étant des actives
il y a deux siècles je soupçonne qu'on
les comptait pas mais il y a deux
siècles la fraction de la population
active qui travaillait dans
l'agriculture dans ce pays c'était les
deux tiers
donc les deux tiers des actifs dans ce
pays travaillaient dans l'agriculture du
coup si vous faites une règle du pouce
en disant tous les gens sont payés
pareil ou qui travaillent ça revient à
dire que les deux tiers du PIB étaient
agricoles ce qui revient à dire que les
deux tiers de la consommation enfin les
deux tiers des dépenses de consommation
étaient agricoles modulo les impôts et
quelques transferts mais en gros l'ordre
de grandeur était là donc entre la
moitié et les deux tiers
aujourd'hui comme vous le savez
probablement l'agriculture c'est 2% du
PIB ce qui veut dire que le prix de la
nourriture stricto sensu je n'inclus pas
son transport je n'inclut pas son
emballage je n'inclut pas sa
transformation et je n'incluse surtout
pas le salaire du magazinier ou du
serveur si vous allez chez Carrefour ou
si vous allez manger une omelette au bar
tabac du coin
et bien ça veut dire que le prix de la
nourriture stricte au sensu c'est 2% de
ce qu'on gagne aujourd'hui 2 % de ce
qu'on gagne c'était entre la moitié et
les deux tiers de ce qu'on gagnait il y
a de siècles donc le monde agricole a
vécu un effondrement de sa part relative
dans la richesse un effondrement et
c'est l'un de ses drames aujourd'hui
parce que comment demander à un monde
d'innover férocement et il va devoir
innover férocement alors qu'il est
pauvre vous allez me dire non il y a
quelques céréaliers qui sont riches ok
les globalement le monde agricole est
pauvre au regard des autres domaines
économiques et il est très pauvre au
regard de sa fonction dans la société
qui est que s'il n'est pas là vous
pouvez oublier les 98% restants du PIB
sauf à ce qu'on arrive à faire faire du
PIB à des fantômes et des zombies
compliqué de faire d'avoir une activité
économique quand on ne mange plus
donc c'est ça qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui enfin c'est ça qui s'est
passé sur le dernier siècle ça a été une
profonde transformation et cette
profonde transformation par ailleurs
s'est opérée dans un climat qui restait
stable pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont
envie de regarder plus loin dans
l'histoire le passage aux activités
agricoles de notre espèce et sa
sédentarisation il y a 10 ans ont été la
conséquence directe de la stabilisation
du climat qui s'est opérée à cette
époque-là il y a jusqu'à il y a 10 000
ans le climat était soit très froid soit
instable c'est à dire que on a eu soit
une période glaciaire pendant laquelle
toutes les moyennes latitudes étaient
totalement incultivables soit une
déglaciation entre il y a 20 000 ans et
il y a 10 000 ans pendant laquelle
incidemment le climat s'est réchauffé
que de 4 à 5 degrés en moyenne
planétaire donc produit quand même des
gros gros changements 4 à 5 degrés dans
la moyenne planétaire
et pendant cette dégraissation le niveau
de l'eau est remonté de 120 mètres la
France qui ressemblait au nord de la
Sibérie c'est bizarre ressembler à ce à
quoi elle ressemble aujourd'hui donc
c'est quelques petits chamboulements et
depuis 10000 ans le climat est stable et
donc un certain nombre de population
humaine ce sont sédentarisés et ont pu
développer une production agricole dans
sa demandait d'autres conditions ça
demandait des espèces sauvages qui
pouvaient être domestiquées ça demandait
éventuellement des animaux qui pouvaient
être domestiqués etc c'est très bien
d'expliquer dans le bouquin de
l'inégalité parmi les sociétés de Jared
Diamond si vous l'avez pas lu je vous
invite à le lire mais ça demandait aussi
une stabilité climatique sans laquelle à
l'époque des sociétés humaines assez peu
résilientes n'aurait pas pu changer en
permanence leur pratique au fil d'une
d'un climat se modifiant et étant encore
raisonnablement changeant donc c'est
donc c'est on est les descendants
aujourd'hui de deux choses l'abondance
énergétique qui c'est surtout
matérialisée sur les deux derniers
siècles la stabilité climatique qui
s'était matérialisée sur les derniers
millénaires
nous allons quitter ces deux domaines de
stabilité nous sommes en train de
quitter ces deux domaines de stabilité
il suffit pour ceux d'entre vous qui
savoureraient un journal de regarder ce
qui se passe en ce moment en Espagne ce
qui s'apprête à se passer en France cet
été puisque nous démarrons la saison de
pousse et nous démarrons le printemps et
l'été avec des nappes phréatiques qui
sont dans un niveau très bas
et avec des précipites des
précipitations qui font maintenant
défaut en France depuis en gros deux ans
et en Espagne depuis en gros trois ans
c'est malheureusement très cohérent avec
ce que les simulations climatiques nous
promettent pour l'avenir puisque dans le
cadre du réchauffement climatique il est
prévu que il y ait un assèchement
progressif du pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen c'est malheureusement
quelque chose qui est dans les
modélistes dans les résultats de
modélisation donc c'est comme le port
salut c'est marqué dessus
malheureusement on n'avait pas très
envie d'aller regarder mais c'est
quelque chose qui est connu depuis un
certain temps un certain temps
donc on va quitter la stabilité
climatique et le climat va devenir
globalement plus hostile pour
l'agriculture en tout cas en France le
climat va s'assécher les précipitations
vont devenir plus irrégulières et donc
vous savez que des précipitations plus
irrégulières c'est une fraction d'eau
qui reste dans le sol qui baisse puisque
les épisodes intenses ne donnent lieu
qu'à peu d'infiltration par rapport au
volume d'eau qui tombe pour ça il vaut
beaucoup mieux du crash en breton j'ai
rien contre les Bretons c'est de la
Bretagne est un pays où il fait beau
trois fois par jour beaucoup la Bretagne
mais c'est les précipitations type
crache un Breton qui sont des
précipitations qui sont utiles et
intéressantes pour les aides pour le
pour le les végétaux
donc on va avoir des précipitations plus
irrégulières on va avoir une évaporation
qui va augmenter puisqu'il va faire plus
chaud et donc les sols vont globalement
s'asser d'à peu près 10% par degré de
réchauffement global c'est ça le le ce
qu'il faut garder en tête pour le
pourtour du bassin méditerranéen donc 4
degrés de réchauffement global 40 %
d'assèchement pour les 4 degrés c'est
pas sûr qu'on les aie parce qu'à mon
avis on va avoir une économie qui va
s'effondrer avant mais 2 à 3 degrés on
est on est bien parti pour et c'est déjà
quelque chose absolument massif
on va également avoir un problème avec
les forêts bon ça ça concerne pas
directement l'agriculture mais enfin ça
concerne un tout petit peu comment on
les appelle siphins non c'est pas ça ce
qui partent à Nancy là les filles
donc ça concerne quand même une partie
des des gens qui s'occupent en gros de
domestiquer des espèces végétales pour
qu'on en fasse quelque chose
d'intéressant pour l'humanité
et on va également avoir un gros
problème avec les arbres avec le enfin
problème encore plus aigu puisque les
cultures annuelles on peut avoir l'INRA
qui vous suit et puis tous les ans aux
plantes des trucs un peu différents avec
les arbres c'est un peu plus compliqué
parce qu'il faut attendre un demi-siècle
entre le moment où on plante et le
moment où on récolte donc on peut pas
jouer tous les ans à faire quelque chose
de différent
on va donc sortir de la stabilité
climatique on va avoir un certain nombre
de conséquences adverses qui vont
apparaître par exemple la compétition
entre espèces va se mettre à changer il
y a quelques années il y avait de l'eau
idiome qui commençait à s'attaquer aux
bourgeons alors que avant il arrivait
plus tard et qui s'attaquait aux
feuilles ça fait toute la différence
évidemment sur les espèces parce que si
vous attaquez aux feuilles l'arbre quand
même les moyens de résister si vous
attaquez au bourgeons il résiste pas
vous avez de l'oidium par exemple qui
remonte et du mildiou qui parle pas du
mildiou qui remonte maintenant plus au
nord dans les vignes vous avez etc donc
la compétition entre espèces va changer
avec une capacité à anticiper qui n'est
pas extraordinaire moi l'ingénieur je
resterai modeste devant les biologistes
parce que la vie c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué beaucoup beaucoup plus
compliqué que le climat donc il y a
beaucoup de choses là-dedans qui sont
très difficiles à anticiper et
malheureusement on constatera les pertes
postes beaucoup plus que on ne va être
capable de comprendre très à l'avance la
manière dont le système pourrait se
comporter
et puis à ça il faut ajouter la question
énergétique donc je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure les combustibles fossiles sont
pas éternels d'abord on voudrait s'en
passer pour des raisons climatiques et
même si on n'arrive pas à s'en passer
pour des raisons climatiques ce qui est
plutôt ce qu'on fait en ce moment et
bien la déplétion géologique va se
charger de faire la voiture balai et va
également nous causer quelques
limitations et venir un peu diminuer
notre costume de Superman ou d'Iron Man
qui aujourd'hui nous rendons service
alors en Europe on est déjà parti dans
la seringue
l'approvisionnement pétrolier de
l'Europe pardon et déjà
contraint à la baisse depuis 2008 qui
est l'année où la production mondiale de
pétrole est passée par son pic pour le
pétrole conventionnel dans tout ce qui
n'est pas pétrole de schiste américain
et sable bitumineux du Canada et pour
tous les pétroles mondiaux y compris
schis y compris sable bitumineux pardon
et pétrole de schiste il n'est pas exclu
que ce soit 2018 quand encore un peu tôt
pour le savoir le covid a un peu
brouillé la vue
mais il n'est pas exclu que ce soit 2018
et si c'est pas 2018 ça sera avant 2030
de toute façon
l'Europe est totalement importatrice de
pétrole depuis que la Grande-Bretagne et
la quitté et que la Norvège n'y a jamais
été si on regarde l'Europe géographique
c'est-à-dire la mer du Nord combien
est-ce que la mère du Nord fournit de
pétrole à l'Europe ça doit on est entre
15 et 20% en ce moment tout le reste est
important de loin d'ailleurs pour lequel
on est en compétition avec d'autres pays
et puis s'il y a de moins en moins de
pétrole les producteurs vont garder de
plus en plus pour leur propre population
et en exporter de moins en moins
quantité de pétrole qui va rentrer en
Europe d'ici à 2050 devrait être divisé
par 2 à 20 climat ou pas climat
alors certes on a un objectif de
neutralité normalement c'est 0 mais même
si on n'a pas d'objectif de neutralité
ça va être divisé par 2 à 20
donc on va avoir un sujet sur la
mécanisation agricole mais pas que on va
également avoir un sujet de vitalité des
zones rurales qui sont globalement plus
dépendantes de la voiture individuelle
qui sont plus globalement plus
dépendantes de un certain nombre de
transports etc donc on va avoir un sujet
on va avoir un sujet de vitalité
économique tout court parce que
aujourd'hui les transports sont
indispensables à l'économie et depuis
aussi longtemps que je regarde le sujet
le PIB mondial a tendance à varier comme
la quantité de pétrole produite sur
terre
donc ça veut dire que avec moins de
pétrole et une économie qui n'est pas
capable de se décarboner à la bonne
vitesse on a globalement moins
d'économies
et ça ça veut dire que globalement
l'arbitrage de la collectivité se
modifie alors est-ce que les gens quand
ils auront moins d'argent ils vont
continuer à avoir un smartphone et à
regarder Netflix et il mangeront que des
pâtes ou ils vont manger un peu mieux
que des pâtes ils vont manger des
légumes et ils auront un smartphone de
moins bonne qualité c'est difficile de
savoir aujourd'hui comment les gens
comment les gens arbitres mais il va y
avoir des questions de cette nature qui
vont se poser en gros on va se remettre
on va retrouver de plus en plus de la
concurrence d'usage dans le budget des
ménages parce que c'est ça qu'on a dans
une économie en contraction sous
contrainte de déplétion fossile c'est de
la concurrence d'usage dans le budget
des ménages il est absolument évident
que dans ce contexte là s'il n'y a pas
du côté de la puissance publique
des arbitrages très clairs qui sont
faits en disant c'est plus important de
faire ça plutôt que de faire ça
les secteurs longs et l'agriculture est
un secteur long les changements ça met
une voire deux générations à se produire
ne serait-ce que parce que
traditionnellement le terroir c'est une
tradition c'est donc ne pas bouger ne
rien changer on fait du comté dans la
zone à où c'est compter il est pas
question qu'on commence à faire du comté
dans les Landes d'accord et on fait des
asperges dans les Landes et on fait pas
d'asperges à Strasbourg bon donc
l'agriculture c'est une activité de
terroir et le terroir et c'est une
activité de tradition et donc gérer un
changement rapide dans une activité qui
est pas récent une activité de tradition
c'est très compliqué c'est très
compliqué et c'est pas facile à faire du
tout
donc on va avoir des sujets de
transition et il est absolument évident
que le secteur agricole tout seul dans
son coin voir le secteur agroalimentaire
tout seul dans son coin il y arrivera
pas
alors dans les conclusions personnelles
auxquelles tout ce que je viens de voir
vous raconter ma mène moi j'en ai une
première qui est on peut pas demander à
un secteur d'innover s'il reste pauvre
donc il y a un vrai sujet qui est que il
faut faire suffisamment de pédagogie
pour que la population accepte que la
nourriture voit son prix augmenter et
quand je dis que la nourriture voit son
prix augmenter je parle pas des marges
de Carrefour
je parle vraiment de ce qui rentre dans
de ce qui rentre dans les exploitations
la deuxième chose c'est que le monde
agricole va probablement devoir évoluer
dans le sens d'une diversification de
ces productions parce que la
spécialisation des régions est un truc
qui est très cohérent avec des
transports abondants si les transports
deviennent moins abondants et que donc
la résilience alimentaire doit
s'organiser à l'échelle du département
ou de la région ça veut dire que une
partie des régions agricoles on doit les
dés spécialisées mais si on les a
spécialisés c'est précisément parce
qu'on avait les rendements maximaux dans
les cultures dans lesquelles on les a
spécialisés donc en des spécialisant on
fait baisser les rendements donc gagnant
résilience sur la longueur de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement mais on va perdre en
rendement fatalement donc on fait monter
les prix totalement
la troisième conclusion à laquelle
j'arrive c'est que il faut que les
agriculteurs seuls ou en se regroupant
avec des petites coopératives etc
intègre de la valeur ajoutée à la balle
donc il faisait du lait font des yaourts
ils font des fromages il faisait des
légumes ils font de la ratatouille etc
donc je pense que c'est il y a aussi et
parce que c'est il y a que comme ça qui
vont arriver à faire rentrer plus
d'emplois dans les exploitations
agricoles et il est nécessaire de faire
rentrer de l'emploi dans les
exploitations agricoles mais on peut pas
faire entrer les emplois chez les gens
qui sont pauvres donc un moment faut
faire rentrer du pognon pas de miracle
on a un sujet
important qui est que l'agriculture donc
ça reste une activité qui est
raisonnablement locale mais sa gestion
aujourd'hui est devenue raisonnablement
supranationale puisque l'essentiel de
l'activité agricole française et régie
par la politique agricole commune
qui est un domaine dans lequel il n'y a
pas de subir il y a peu de subsidiarité
le c'est quand même bon et donc là on a
un vrai sujet qui est comment est-ce que
on gère vu d'en haut une activité qui va
devoir s'adapter au changement
climatique de manière très localisée
parce que le changement climatique est
pas le même ici qu'ailleurs et qui va
devoir se
on va dire se dés spécialiser donc la
politique agricole commune c'était un
truc qui était très très bien adapté
quand on avait des marchés mondiaux sur
des commodités avec des régions très
monoculture
mais ça ça marche bien dans un monde au
climat stable sans problème
environnementaux sans érosion des sols
sans baisse de la biodiversité et sans
problème d'approvisionnement en énergie
fossile je m'arrête ça va être un peu
plus compliqué de gérer ça dans un monde
dans lequel on a tous les défis à
relever que je viens d'évoquer voilà
donc on me dit qu'il faut que je
m'arrête parce que je suis trop bavard
donc je m'arrête là voilà mais les
quelques conclusions et en particulier
il y en a une vraiment cardinale c'est
il faut faire rentrer de l'argent dans
le secteur donc à mon avis c'est ça la
première question à se poser c'est
comment on fait